pas parler des réseaux sociaux justement
puisque de plus en plus de seniors se
lancerait en tant qu influenceurs sur
internet je t'aime et cetera est revenu
sur ce phénomène
direction le shooting pour sylvie line
stag rameuses au plus de 10000 abonnés
on pousse avec le bateau derrière cette
recul à j'adore et comme toute bonne une
star rameuses qui se respecte sylvie
n'oublie pas de tenir au courant ses
abonnés de son activité du jour et
qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui ma
belle des fautes et bombay coutume
envoie les photos que la semaine
prochaine pas le temps d'attendre les
photos du shooting d'aujourd'hui c'est
lui doit alimenter son compte d'être
connecté et d'être sûr tous les réseaux
sociaux c'est une vraie plus value tous
ces regards bienveillants vous donne un
autre regard sur vous et vous donne
encore plus de facilité pour avancer en
âge
quel est votre hashtag préféré alors ça
serait hashtag junior parce que il est
plein de vie
dit bien ce qui veut dire on est jeunes
et seniors en même temps la contraction
des deux voilà donc c'est un peu la
catégorie dans laquelle le je me trouve
à leur attention mais attention vous
allez dire qu'est ce qu'on en pense de
ces seniors influenceurs sur un
programme parce que je vous rappelle que
je vais avoir 50 ans cet été
je fais donc partie de la bande la wii
un jeu des jeunes seniors moi je les
adore je trouve que la paix y compris
franchement s'ils disent et voilà elle a
tous les codes il n'y a pas de raison
que ça s'ouvre pas à des à des gens
voilà un petit arrêt soulagé oui je
trouve que c'est fantastique en plus
c'est vrai qu'on dit souvent que les
personnes un peu âgées elles sont un
petit peu seules elles reçoivent
peut-être moins de visites de messages
de trucs gentils et tout donc
franchement fait fait comme s'il y en
plus ils ont raison c'est vrai que c'est
la mode est réservé à tout le monde
les cosmétiques la beauté bon je vois là
je sais que thibaut début l'annoncé je
rappelle quand même que est considéré
comme seniors en entreprise quelqu'un à
partir de 40 50 quand même très jeune
moi je dis ça parce que je précise que
rwe et eon et dans le marketing ces cinq
ans à partir de 50 ans qu'on est en
seniors thibault je suis un angoissé
faits réels mais non pas parce que vous
faites partie des seniors basile jamais
ils commencent à arriver dans mon coeur
vous ferez partie des seniors on devait
tout pimpant mais cette sylvie faut
qu'elle mette son compte en privé tout
simplement mais pourquoi ça sonne faux
c'est un décalage c'est comme si je
chantais à l'opéra je vous ai pardon
pardon mais ça veut dire que à partir de
45 ans on ne peut plus être
prescriptrice de mode on peut plus
parler d'eux et bien sûr une visite en
russie mais avec la famille les amis
là il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas et
un côté ridicule r vous avez tout le
monde a souri dans le public et si tout
on a souri en la voyant ils vont vous
regardez donc voilà ça va
[Rires]
ça veut dire alors je vais prendre un
cas un cas très très personnel moi j'ai
un blog par exemple et ggb donc avoir 50
ans vous estimez que normalement il faut
pas qu'on me suivre et vous n'avez rien
à faire avec ces personnes là vous êtes
dans une autre sphère
enfin mais qu'elles font qu arrêter
c'est considéré comme mort dans ces cas
n'a pas démérité jeudi à vérines
également dans le côté amateur un peu
risible et c'est dommage
il faudrait professionnaliser le truc
comme vous faites peut-être
pourriez-vous les zones et des cours
vous êtes alors vous qui d'habitude être
cynique là vous êtes le roi des faux
culs des compères de ramer comme pape a
aussi une âme et yann explications il
est la place de damien nos kilos si elle
n'a jamais autant parlé de lui que
qu'aujourd'hui vous a pas payé info le
prévenir parce que david a dit dans sa
télé en mode un génial mais non dans tes
papilles et damien même sur parle de toi
moi j'adore l'idée j'en peux plus de
voir les cagoles et les îles et rick
gagnent des sommes monstrueuses être
influenceurs de fait pas trop quoi peut
pas non plus maintenant on veut dire
mais tous les to les influenceurs de 20
ans sont des cagoules ou des illettrés
en parla pas mal quand même
et là ça me fait plaisir d'autant plus
que des seniors on ne sait très bien
aujourd'hui on l'a dit suffisamment sur
ce plateau
ils n'ont pas beaucoup de sous donc je
suis contente de voir certains ténors
qui disent ah bah on va les prendre le
truc des petits jeunes à l'inversé de ce
qu'ils font d'habitude et on va faire de
la tune sur leur dos donc je trouve ça
génial bravo sylvie et bravo taquin et
nicole et tout le monde est par ailleurs
c'est bien ici de dire que c'est pas
parce qu'on a on arrive à l'âge
canonique de 45 ans et plus qu'on a plus
qu on a plus le droit à la mode qu'on a
plus le droit aux gadgets qu'on a plus
droit à ce genre de choses ils iront n'a
fait justement un sujet sur sur sa sur
les cadeaux sur les cadeaux que vous
êtes
jimmy qu'est ce que vous en pensez
écoutez je suis de ceux qui pensent que
les influenceurs ne servent pas à grand
chose
c'est bien cela
mais peu importe la gms et son histoire
est très sympa oui alors on laquelle on
la met dans la classe senior comme si
elle était très vieille mais elle a quel
âge 50 ans 55 ans 60 ans c'est pas ça la
vieillesse c'est pas ça pour moi être
senior et de seniors c'est lorsqu'on
rentre peut-être dans la phase un peu de
dépendance mais les influenceurs la de
20 ans qui apporte rien qui ont pas de
qui veut dire comparer leurs dorgler
millions de vues sur instagram à mon
titre de docteur en médecine
elle m'a parlé de dire que vous estimez
pas ce qu un influenceur en fait c'est
un mannequin c'est à dire qu'il vend un
produit pour enfin que tu marqué par
exemple pour vous le mannequinat les
mannequins sont passés par métier par
vrai métier c'est pas moi c'est pas un
vrai métier comme boulanger comme
mécanicien comme policier c'est
peut-être un métier on me dira qu
influenceurs c'est un métier mais qu'est
ce qu'ils apportent à part ces décès des
gens qui font de la pub et qui viennent
de l'argent en faisant de la pub c'est
juste des publicitaires déguisés qui
coûte pas très cher conseil disque avec
rennes mais quand on prend la relève et
jamais vous aussi vous avez refusé à
juste chroniqueur c'est un métier où on
en est non non moi je cours je considère
pas que creuser par métier de paix je
comprendrais à dire non mais moi je te
prennent à des bandes argentées poste
c'est bon ça tue le cochon à l'homme
mais je vais pas me cacher de faire sa
renommée dans le monde de jimmy on se
ferait chier je veux dire n'y aurait pas
de comédien n'aurait pas de mannequin
n'y aurait pas d' acteurs devraient pas
de réalisateur minoré de memri rien
amélioré des médecins j'aurais pu
d'origine
by ap bon d'accord
donc non mais pour vous voilà on
considérait pas que c'est sérieux non
c'est pas sérieux le temps le slip aux
imaginaires aussi que c'est comme le
disait thibault parc par exemple un
complément de revenu pour des personnes
qui sont à la retraite et qui du coup
pour arrondir arriver là pour que une ou
deux personnes puissent accéder à cette
sphère
on nous dit qu'elle a dit 1000 followers
très bien la dîme il faut leur jeu parce
que ça change mais qu'on a qu'on
augmente finalement le minimum
vieillesse les retraites qu'on ne
commette et ludique la sfl aziz jabbar
ont mal d'argent on parle de lui et il a
mené les buts tant qu'à faire tant mieux
si elle arrivait pour cette dame très
bien mais quand on prend ce qu'ils font
les trucs mais que plat et qu'on se rend
compte qu'elles mentent tout et que
finalement la lumière artificielle que
finalement le maquillage une fois qu'on
leur produit à la maison
eh ben on n'a pas exactement la même
chose mais que derrière les organes et
des milliers d'euros et que nous on a
acheté le produit comme des idiots je
pense que ce n'est pas un vrai métier le
coach d'auxerre strictement à rien ça
n'apporte rien au cou comme toi j'ai des
réserves sur le métier d'influenceurs
mais y en a certaines et notamment je
pense à des angels phoenix qui ont eu
voilà le courage notamment d'apparaître
sur les réseaux sociaux sans maquillage
et dire aux jeunes filles
ouais j'ai de la cne mais c'est pas
grave si vous en avez aussi vous
inquiétez pas par ailleurs il ya six
mois par ailleurs il ya de plus en plus
maintenant c'est vrai que vous êtes
resté peut-être sur les premières
influences euse qui rit regard il
hériterait un autre monde mais il ya des
influences qui prennent des positions je
pense à chérac et rien de ce qu'ils ont
connaît bien ici et qui est formidable
et qui notamment dit au jeune fille
assumez vous assumez vos rondeurs
assumées qui vous êtes assumez vos
racines et de vie dans ces cas-là mais
qu'on va pas s'enfermer tout et
n'importe quoi
coach de vie pourquoi pas psychologue ok
très bien mais pas influenceurs je
trouve que ça va d'accord je crois que
c'est un métier que ça va venir et
nommait les jeunes non plus dire je
devenir policier j'ai devenir
influenceurs bon bah dites nous ce que
vous en pensez avec le hashtag sécu des
lt